representa la presencia de este
armamento en las malvinas que mensaje
envía a argentina
bueno obviamente el mensaje es de
disuación lo que se ha hecho es cambiar
el sistema de defensa que había de
misiles rápida con uno más moderno más
avanzado con mayor capacidad mayor
distancia no es un armamento antiaéreo
defensivo no no
hay un gran debate sobre el efecto de
esas armas y la argentina por supuesto
que responde como ha estado respondiendo
cada vez que gran bretaña instalaba
instaló la base monte están instaló
nuevos radares desplegó aviones de
combate digamos siempre gran bretaña
éste mantiene el estado de un estado de
defensa que alcanza para las capacidades
que tiene en este momento la república
argentina pero el mensaje es este me
parece que coincide con los movimientos
que está realizando la argentina de
acercarse a china ahora qué tan probable
es que se reanuden las negociaciones
sobre la soberanía de las islas malvinas
muy poco probables porque este gobierno
el actual que digamos este gobierno
antes del presidente macri que estaba
antes no tenía ninguna no tiene una
postura de negociar las malvinas excepto
que sea que gran bretaña diga que va a
entregar soberanía que era la postura
que tenía el gobierno militar en cuando
decidió ocupar recuperar a las islas en
1982 o sea la diferencia entre la
argentina y el reino unido- es que el
reino unido- habla de la
autodeterminación de los isleños y la
argentina habla de que va a respetar los
intereses eso es lo que se acordó en las
resoluciones de naciones unidas e insta
a las partes a que se pongan de acuerdo
de cómo van a resolver el problema o sea
en ese sentido las naciones niñas
tampoco son de una gran de una gran
ayuda no porque éste no resuelve ese
problema o sea reconocemos a la
población como como nativa o esteo
autodeterminación o directamente la
postura argentina que es la misma de los
países de latinoamérica uti possidetis
es la continuación de nuestro de nuestra
a continuación desde españa en la
independencia española de los
territorios que pertenecían a españa ese
es el núcleo de la discusión entonces
hablar de transferencia de hablar de
negociación es este es estar dispuesto a
una cosa o la otra el gobierno argentino
no está dispuesto a ceder un ápice de la
postura de soberanía total y los
británicos tampoco